i didn't have a rich father
not from uh you know well educated i
said i
tried it three times for university all
filled
i applied for harvard for 10 times all
field they don't want to see me for the
last time
i went to the teacher's college which
was considered
the third or fourth class of my city
but i think that is the best university
i've ever had
so i applied jobs for 30 times
got rejected i went for a police they
said no you're not good
i went to even the kfc when kfc came to
china company
20 24 people went for the job
23 people accepted i was the only guy
and we went for police five people four
of them accepted i was the only guy that
i received
i i don't think in this world a lot of
people be rejected more than 30 times
i think we have to get used to it we're
not that good
even today we still have a lot of people
reject us
i think that is a normal life
right and i i believe that
it was so difficult at that time i was
so frustrated
because i taught in the university my
pay was ten dollars a month
was not easy but i believe that
something
something is waiting for me there and i
have to work hard
to prove myself in 1994 discuss that i'm
going to do
something called internet and 23 of them
against it they say this is a stupid
idea
right we have never heard about the
internet and you know nothing about
computer
why you want to do the computer nobody
believed that i could be successful
because everybody say well this guy
think differently thinker crazily you
know they think about something never
work
i believe it because i saw the computer
in 1994 when i went to usa
i think this thing could be big but
i never thought it would be that big
like today
so if i can make a site that can help
chinese products
selling outside and helping the small
business in the other country
sell to the other part of the world that
was the concept so 1999
i studied alibaba in my apartment
for the first three years we do not have
even one dollar revenue from our
business
but why it keeps on going ahead
going forward because i received
lots of email of thanks
from the customer we have a lot of we
have
alibaba group we have a team all group
we have a taobao group we have
alipay and people say how you make it
why people cannot find opportunities and
why i don't have this chance
and i think where is the opportunity the
opportunity lie always lies
in the place where people complain
some people sit there complain you think
if i can solve that complaint
that's the opportunity that's what i did
my my view is that if when you are 20 to
30 years old
you should follow a good boss join a
good company to learn
how to do things properly when you're 30
to 40 years old
if you want to do something yourself
just do it
you still can't afford to lose to fail
but when you're 40 to 50 years old
my suggestion is that you should do
things that you are good at right
and not do things that oh that's very
interesting i want to try something new
it's been dangerous more when you're 50
to 60 years old
spending time training and developing
young people the next generation
we are at the best of time of this
century
the best the best assets you have
is that you are young don't complain
let the other people complain i saw a
lot of people
young people have fantastic ideas every
evening but in the morning they go to
the office stream again
make the move make the action to
everybody to any person tomorrow is new
whether investors believe in this or not
whether your friends
believe it or not whether your parents
believe it or not
that's not important you believe it your
team believe it and work
day and night on this that's all the
things happens
make enough mistakes don't worry
you fall you stand up you fall you step
this is also another last advice i want
to give you either work for the others
or work for yourself and i choose the
way i work
my for myself but working for myself
that means working for the society if
you really want to work for yourself
think about the others because only when
the other
other people are successful when the
other people are happy
you'll be successful you will be happy
[Music]